the very latest on the pandemic there
are now more than a quarter of a million
known cases of the corona virus in the
US the death toll has topped seventy one
hundred it's led the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention to recommend that
everyone wear face coverings in public
that comes as hard-hit states such as
New York and Louisiana try to get
ventilators and other life-saving
medical equipment to meet the surge of
patients flooding emergency rooms and
field hospitals some relief was trucked
into New York City on Friday courtesy of
New England Patriots owner Robert Kraft
he had 300,000 n95 masks flown in from
China they were brought in to help
protect frontline health care workers
Michael George is at New York's pier 90
where the US Navy's hospital ship
comfort is docked Michael good morning
Jeff Dana good morning US hospitals
especially here in New York are at their
breaking point that's why the u.s. naval
ship comfort was brought here to try and
take on some of the non kovat patients
and free up some hospital beds the
situation here is so dire New York
City's mayor says hospitals don't have
enough ventilators to make it through
the week the curve continues to go up
the number of tests has reached a new
high and so have the deaths more than
one in three lives lost were in the
state of New York outside a Brooklyn
Hospital a makeshift morgue had to be
set up in a refrigerator truck other big
cities were on a hard watch by dr.
Deborah burns the coronavirus response
coordinator for the White House's
coronavirus task force we continue to
watch in addition the Chicago area the
Detroit area and have some developing
concerns around Colorado the District of
Columbia and Pennsylvania by Friday
Pennsylvania's cases were rising at the
rate of a thousand a day and Governor
Tom Wolf's appealed the citizens to help
the only way we can cut the growth of
this fires is to act as if we all have
it today I'm asking all Pennsylvanians
to wear a mask any time you leave your
house and already hard-hit Louisiana
projects 2,500 new hospital cases a day
by mid-may if the virus continues to
spread at the current rate already 370
people have died in that state where
people have been ordered to stay at home
41 states and the District of Columbia
now have similar orders in place our
message is this what are you waiting for
what more evidence do you need
California's governor Gavin Newsom
criticized state governors who have not
ordered citizens to stay home his state
was the first one to put an order in
place three weeks ago now the state with
a population nearly twice the size of
New York has a tenth of the coronavirus
cases
ninety percent of all US citizens have
been ordered to stay home many unable to
work some nine million people had filed
for unemployment insurance over the past
two weeks but many unemployment offices
are closed requiring people to file
claims
online cutting people like rowdy Bay out
of the counts increasing evidence shows
the poor are at a greater disadvantage
many in service industry jobs are not
staying home risking the virus in order
to survive financially but the greatest
exposure comes in hospitals and for
first responders some places are
offering incentives for retired doctors
and nurses to come back to work under
conditions no one could have imagined
and the naval ship comfort has a
thousand beds for non coronavirus
patients but as of Thursday night only
20 of those beds were actually being
used now the Navy says they've cleared
up some of the red tape including
allowing ambulances to bring patients
directly onto the pier and doing on-site
coronavirus testing and officials say
they are considering converting the ship
to handle coronavirus patients Jeff all
right Michael thank you very much